The Pearson product-moment correlation measures the strength of relationship
between any two variables, but there can be lots
of other types of relationships. Even other ones that
are monotonic, either increasing or decreasing. So we also
have measures of monotonic relationships, such as a rank
correlation measures like Spearman. We can assign Spearman to
the method parameter and calculate the correlation that way.
Here we have a different test statistic called Ï,
and notice how our value is slightly different as well.
You can learn more about the assumptions and uses of the
different methods in the instructor notes. From these last couple
correlation videos, the main point I want to make here is that
single number coefficients like this are useful, but they are
not a grid substitute for looking at a scatter plot and
computing conditional summaries like we did earlier. We have a
richer understanding by looking at such plots like this one for
friend_count and age.